pour les restaurateurs vous le savez
c'est une année noire de confinement et
pas d'ouverture pour les fêtes
alors comment combattre cette morosité
et bien à tour des chefs ont décidé de
cuisiner ensemble le temps d'un week end
le résultat un menu emporté un bon
moment entre amis
aurélie renault romain julien et antoine
trois talents pour un menu d'exception
nous sommes dans les cuisines du petit
miche chez antoine son restaurant a
ouvert il ya un an et demi il était
beaucoup trop paisible à son goût en
cette période de confinement antoine a
appelé deux amis cuisinier pour un grand
week end de gastronomie ya du bruit
c'est dégueulasse
mais bon ça fait du bien c'est on
utilise le matériel on utilise de la
bonne came enfin dans ce fait beaucoup
plaisir
au menu il y a entre autres des
tartelettes de courges et de truffe
noire
et alors que le lard de colonnata
compote avec les oignons
romain lui savoure les retrouvailles ces
prochains mois il devrait ouvrir son
propre restaurant à tour cette
collaboration à six mains lui donne un
avant goût de ce qui l'attend ce qui
fait le plus de bien c'est vraiment au
raid retrouvez une cuisine aussi
professionnel c'est en effet c'est les
bruits et les odeurs c'est hier soir on
a accueilli les clients enfin c'est un
tout c'est une passion ou toute façon ça
c'est certain
des pieds puis encore une fois c'est les
copains à cette fois ci qui font leur
remonter le moral
du côté des desserts c'est julien qui
officie il prépare le caramel au beurre
salé qui n'a pas le saint-honoré
blogueur cuisine sous le pseudo julien
aubert il avait collaboré avec antoine
pour des desserts de saint-valentin
récemment pendant le confinement lui les
romains avaient également travaillé
ensemble il ya un mois je crois on a
fait un live facebook pour terres du son
pour le festival pourront cuisiner
ensemble et c'est la première fois qu'on
à cuisiner ensemble donc là voilà et
c'est la première fois qu'on cuisine
pour le coup tous les 3es en fait c'est
toujours chouette d'aller voir ce que
pour les copains est ce qu'ils font à
manger et c'est vrai que là il ya des
choses qui vont traîner au dessus du
four en général on passe on grignote
confiné ou non les trois chefs
cuisiniers n'exclut pas de nouvelles
collaborations en 2021